that's it's math it's
just not my favorite thing
hey there everybody now uh yeah there
are actually going to
be two lgbtq plus representation videos
this month
kind of because this one here is a
follow-up
to last month's uh what that i did on
the barrier gays trip because
i realized not long after the video went
up there was an aspect of that
it's actually really important that i
completely forgot to cover
and i debated whether or not it was
worth a whole nother video and
yeah kind of is so this is
supplementary supplementary
to that previous video so i would
recommend checking that out if you
haven't
already but i'll also mention that this
particular video is
sponsored by the radio versus the
martians podcast it's a panel show where
host mike gillis and casey dorn
talk about all manner of nerdy things
from batman to wrestling
to vigilante entertainment to planet of
the apes
and of course every single film on his
horse negro is ever in
they have on guests they talk about all
kinds of things they're funny they're
fun
they're sometimes even insightful radio
versus the martians at
radioversesmartians.com or wherever you
get your podcast
so the thing that i forgot to talk about
has to do with basically
the queer mortality rate in
films now you might look back at uh my
barrier gaze video and go wasn't that
what the entire thing was about well
sort of but there's a specific thing
that i really should have drilled in on
and
actually it bugged me so much that i
picked uh the comment
that was left on the video that that
pointed out what i failed to most
succinctly and pinned it as the top
comment
on that video but now i'm going to talk
about it more specifically here
now i don't run numbers
a ton if i can help it especially
if i am able to just find that someone
has already done that
for me when i say run the numbers it's
come up in videos that i've done like
um harry potter and the heteronormative
standard or it came up
ages ago um and i know and uh
doctor who video that i did talking
about the uh
the companion character of bill and
you know things like that where i really
want to back things up with
data it's not my favorite thing to do
and it's also just not
in general how my head tends to work so
if i don't go out of my way to look up
numbers
i don't always think to do that
um and the other cases where i have the
numbers were very central to the point i
was making in this case talking about
barrier gays
it it's an element of it and a big one
but it wasn't the overall point so i
missed it
now when i say run the numbers what
numbers am i talking about
well theoretically there'd be two sets
of numbers
um one of which i am not even gonna
bother with because the amount of
research that i have to do to try and
cover that
i i i don't have the time
i just don't um so what i'm not gonna
touch in
is what percentage of films in which
queer characters
appear um have those characters die
that i'm not even gonna tackle because
trying to figure out all the films that
have
all the films and tv shows or whatever
that have these kinds of characters at
all and
calculating ones where they die versus
ones where they don't and trying to
parse all that out and then trying to
figure out well
what do we count as mainstream versus
niche entertainment do we
weigh everything the same i'm not
touching that what i am going to tackle
instead
is films in which a gay character dies
films and tv i'll be doing both what
percentage of the queer population of
that film
just got killed because
more often than not whenever a
gay trans queer or otherwise lgbtq plus
character
is killed in a film or tv show that they
appear in
that is usually more than 50
of the queer population of that
film or show or comic
or whatever now why does this even
matter at all well it kind of feeds into
the point that i was making
before about the nature of how often you
see this and a part of what makes it hit
harder
when the barrier gaze trope is sort of
put into play
is the fact that it's not just that
you're killing a gay character
you're killing the vast you know
majority population of the gay
characters
in this story sometimes even
a hundred percent of the gay characters
and that really does increase the impact
of the times this trope gets used and
it's something that i wish i'd addressed
so i'm going to do that now so i have
run a few different sets of numbers and
i am also going to talk about
films separate from tv because tv has
kind of its own little wonky
x factors going on with them but as far
as films go
here's how things are going to break
down in the films or film franchises
that i talk about
i am going to be list i am going to be
telling you
you know here are the gay characters
here's how many die
what was the percentage now in some
cases you are not going to get a
straight
percentage so like for example in a in
let's pick a nice easy example brokeback
mountain two gay characters enos
jack jack dies enos lives 50 mortality
rate
for brokeback mountain sounds easy right
well
it is but things get a little bit more
complicated in some
instances because i would call them in
some cases
arguable in some instances on film it is
arguable
either as to whether or not a character
definitely died or if we're simply
dealing with an implied death
or whether or not a character who did
die
was definitely gay if that was only
implied
so in cases like that i will give a
range basically saying look
here's the math for the maximum
mortality rate
and the minimum mortality rate so i'll
actually open up with an example of
that and that would be rent so
rent both the play and the film the uh
gay population of that film either gay
or bisexual
well or transgender depending on what
you consider angel to be
but it's angel collins joanna maureen
joanna maureen live angel dies
collins is still alive at the end of the
story
but he also has an aids diagnosis and
particularly at the time the thing is
set
that is a death sentence so what i would
say on that one
it is arguable so that one makes it a
mortality rate of
25 to 50 percent so sort of
laying that out the way i have let's
start just running some numbers
well uh how about one of the one of the
big ones
harry potter if we take jk rowling's
word that uh dumbledore is in fact
gay that means that this franchise has a
queer mortality rate of 100 percent
even if we assume that grindelwald is
also queer
he gets killed as well uh and that's
in the uh in the final films is it the
seventh or eighth
one of those but he dies too so that's
still 100 mortality right even if we add
in grindelwald
which is arguable philadelphia i'm
calling that one 50
because even though there is say a party
and a group
of queer and gay characters that are
seen none of them are named they're
effectively extras as far as name
characters go
we have two one of them dies 50
mortality rate there
v for vendetta that's probably
reasonably 100 if you want to be
super generous gordon we don't actually
see
get killed so 50 realistically 100
kiss of the spider woman either 50 or
100 i would call it 100
it's 50 depending on what you consider
rile julie's character to be whether or
not you considered
him to be gay or straight even though
the relationship he has
is with a character played by a man who
is
biologically male it's also a character
who identifies as a woman that makes his
attractions to
the female i would still consider him to
be straight but
if you don't and you want to consider
him to be a gay man that's still a 50
mortality right so we've got 5200 on
that one cloud atlas
two queer characters both dead 100
mortality right
a single man from 33 to 50
depending on what you think about kenny
towards the end because it's
it's implied but that's not a 100
certainty even if we have him in and the
low end is 33 one of the two surviving
gay characters does spend
literally the entire movie contemplating
suicide beginners 50
mortality right rocky or a picture show
one of my favorites so many deprived
characters must have a huge cast
actually when we're talking specifically
queer characters
it's much smaller there's frank there's
rocky
there's brad and maybe arguably there's
eddie we know frank had an attraction to
eddie but because of the nature of
eddie's place in the story we don't know
for sure whether that was ever
reciprocated
from eddie towards frank so that means
we're either dealing with 66
or 75 percent it's high in either case
pulp fiction i bet you're thinking there
were gay characters in pulp fiction
yes there were there was zed
and maynard and the [ __ ]
well um also depends on how we want to
calculate this one out
um maynard's definitely dead zed while
not killed it on
to our eyes as the audience has made
very clear that he is going to be dead
the [ __ ] gets knocked unconscious if we
are super generous
maybe they don't kill him if they assume
that he is
unwilling to this except he seemed
willing and marcellus wallace seems like
he's
really gonna take them all apart so i
would call that a 100 mortality rate
at best 66 so so far
we haven't had a single film in which a
gay character dies that i've cited so
far and again i'm not trying to cherry
pick these
these are the ones that i could
definitely find or think of where
and we haven't had one that was
inarguably
below 50 for the mortality rate the ones
that were below 50
it was a range it was arguable could i
find any
where a queer character died and it
killed
inarguably less than 50 of the queer
cast
yes you're not gonna believe what it was
it was basic instinct there's three
queer characters in that
there's roxy there's beth and of course
there's catherine
roxy dies the other two live 33
mortality rate
on that one we are looking at an overall
mortality rate
of 53 to 68 meaning
if if you are going to a film in which
a queer character dies odds are that's
going to be
more than half the queer population of
that film that you
have to watch get decimated and i'll
also point out
it's pretty common that when we lose 50
the surviving half is one half of a
couple which means the surviving half is
in mourning
so they're suffering too
now i did exclude from this list
anything based off a true story because
obviously you know the creative input
isn't as much at play there
if this is what happened that's the
story they're going to tell
so i didn't i felt like that was going
to be stacking the deck
that said there was something i noticed
taking a quick peek
at films that are queer films
based off true stories a surprisingly
large number of them
opt to tell stories where the gay
character dies
or even the ones where that's not the
case it's pretty common for them to like
in the ending text scroll to explicitly
lay out how they died
so some films that do that would include
milk
boys don't cry before night falls dallas
buyers club the danish girl
behind the candelabra frida can you
forgive me and the imitation game
that i didn't know how to quantify that
pattern
but i noted it and it felt like
something that should be pointed out
so let's get to tv now tv has
additional complications on top of the
ones i already mentioned
about some characters sometimes being
arguable
either their death being arguable or
their status as being queer
being arguable the additional
complication
in television is whether or not
you want to count single appearance
characters
or if you are only going to account for
recurring characters so
most of what the of the numbers i've run
on
television shows um were only
on recurring characters because trying
to
track down whether or not a gay
character appeared like
in a one-off episode of this that or the
other just again
i don't i don't have the time
or the means at this point to be able to
pull that
off so instead i'm gonna focus on main
characters
with one exception there is one show
that i know well enough of the top my
head if you follow this channel you
might even guess what one it is
where i actually am going to break that
down but i'm going to say that towards
the end
but even beyond this there are
additional complications which i'll
mention
as we go along so why don't we talk
about one of the ones that i talked
about in the previous
barrier gaze video let's talk about
buffy the vampire slayer
so in buffy confirmed queer characters
we have
larry willow tara kennedy larry dies
tera dies that is a 50 percent mortality
rate but this also allows me to bring in
the other wrinkle when it comes to
television which is that
when i'm looking at these percentages
i'm looking at the
total run of the show assuming it's
ended
but at the time they happen that
percentage may be a lot worse
so with buffy at the time larry died he
was the only confirmed gay character at
the show so at the time they killed him
at the end of series
at season three that gave the show
100 gay mortality rate then
we established willow as being gay or
bisexual some people prefer i she
identifies as gay but you know
i'll acknowledge that anyway and then
tara so that meant that he'd only lost a
third
and mortality dropped down to 33 until
they killed tara
and suddenly jumps up to 66 until they
introduced kennedy now it's back down to
50.
so you need to kind of decide
for yourself whether later padding out
things uh makes that earlier one okay
and sort of the main reason this
occurred to me was looking at the 100
because this was something that came up
a lot in the comments section of the
previous video
people mentioning alexa now i haven't
watched the 100 so i don't have full
context about this but from what i could
find out
lexa at the time the character died
represented 50 percent of the queer
population of that series
more gay characters have been introduced
since then but at the time she was died
that was 50 gone what else have we got
well
there's torchwood uh for the dead side
of things
we have yanto owen and tosh and
surviving we have
jack harkness and john hart lost is
another one worth
looking at uh just quickly in terms of
that do we count one-off characters
because
the only confirmed recurring character
who was not
straight in that show was tom he died
that gives the show a 100
mortality rate for queer characters
however
technically other queer characters did
appear
in two instances in flashback sequences
meaning basically as background
information
once if you include them the mortality
rate drops to 33
but can we agree that that's a really
generous
interpretation so that's kind of why i
didn't really
uh want to deal too much with one-off
appearances
except for the time that i do and like i
said i'll get back to that because
there is another wrinkle when it comes
to talking about tv shows that
i'm gonna use that to introduce this
whole thing is obviously way less
structured than the last one was
if you couldn't tell so uh voltron 50
mortality
rate and now we come to
doctor who the one that i am gonna run
in two different ways
firstly the way that i have been running
it so dead we have
heather bill and riversong and surviving
we have jenny vastra and
maybe jack harkness the
here's your arguably because i think
it's debatable whether
jack harkness counts as a example
of barrier gaze or a rebuke
of barrier gaze it's possible he might
actually exist as both
so i'm going to give the range on this
and give jack the ability to just
go back and forth and you know do
whatever he wants
so that means that doctor who when
looking at recurring queer characters
has a mortality rate of between 50 and
66
now when i look at one off appearing
queer characters
that does complicate things a bit more
it adds in
on the dead side of things sky silvestri
oswin
the fat one the assistant from arachnids
in the uk
and that one random guard from
resolution meanwhile over on surviving
it adds in
the uh sort of servant from unicorn and
the wasp
the thin one and alonso i lone z alonso
so putting these on board and also
taking into account jack i have to
account for both ways so this is going
to be a range again
this actually makes it worse this makes
it a 60
to 66 range but also i'm going to
illustrate the one other thing because
when looking at a tv show you need to
decide if you are going to look at
the show overall or each individual
episode now
if you're doing something serialized
maybe you want to deal with it one way
if you're doing something episodic maybe
you want to do with the other
but for example in a lot of the
instances of the
single appearance like say midnight the
character of skies
of sky silvestri confirmed as gay does
die and she makes up in the
in that specific episode 100
of the queer characters in that story
so even though the show itself might
have counting characters that are like
sky who appear only one time
a 60 to 66 percent mortality rate
that specific episode has a 100
mortality rate so again the reason
that i wanted to bring all these numbers
up is i think
one of the rebukes to why we shouldn't
even care about barrier gays as a thing
is that
look characters die characters die in
all kinds of stories and all kinds of
characters do
what does this matter well i talked a
lot about
that sort of thing in general in the
previous video but i did kind of fail to
mention the fact that
we're not just watching a gay character
die
oftentimes we're watching the
gay character die or
half of the gay population
of a film die and the instances where it
was
less than half were really small
and even those were often arguable
so when people who are
cisgender or straight
try and think to themselves like well it
doesn't bother me
when you know a straight white guy dies
in a film well
okay no but
what if half of all the straight white
guys
died what if half of all the women
died and not just in a film
in film after film after film
after film minimum
half died because look let's be honest
the instances i found where it was
less than 50 they kind of feel like
flukes
so how would it feel
going into a film
seeing a character that bears a
striking resemblance to you in some key
way
a way that you don't always see depicted
in stories
and you feel like you might as well flip
a coin as to whether or not they live
and if they do die maybe they were it
or they were half and that's why this
that's another reason in addition
everything else i already talked about
why this stuff hits harder
than like maybe some people think it
should
you know looking at it on paper but
the numbers matter i wish i had run them
when i did the previous video
realistically though if i had it would
have been way more condensed it also
would have been more structured i would
have scripted it properly so maybe it
would have worked better in any case
here's me spitting numbers at you
revisiting that topic because of a
pretty hefty omission
so whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments
let's talk about it if you want to help
support me and help me pay my bills and
help make this better there's also a
patreon down there
i've also started putting a link for
paypal tip jar if you
want to do one-time support that's
that's wonderful as well
plus you know there's a whole bunch of
other stuff down there there's links to
my socials linked to my book
p.o box address etc etc etc so
check them out or
don't i am not going to tell you what to
do
i'll suggest i'll hope but i'm not going
to tell you i'm not going to demand
because
at the end of the day folks you are
beautiful
you are loved you are valid you
are the council and i just run the
meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you